No as we all know making political
predictions as charles play dead easy in
fact virtually everything everyone
predicted this time last year for 2017
has come to pass exactly as predicted so
instead let's take a look back at the
year gone by and have a little peek into
the crystal ball at the year ahead with
a distinguished panel of MPs at Labour's
ripper Huck joanna cherry for the SNP
and the Conservative MP Oliver Dayton
very good morning to all of you and this
was of course an election year so that
seems like an appropriate place to begin
Oliver what's the general election of
esteem oh yes of course it was with with
hindsight but most of the people that
were supporting it before it happened
you know there that they support it at
the time so it's all very well for us to
say it's a mistake now you can't
criticize the prime minister for calling
it when when people at the time
supported it themselves but the one
thing the one thing we can all agree on
is that Teresa means longevity you know
when we looked at it in the immediate
aftermath of the general election as
compared to now I mean she's clung on
yeah I mean it's been a bit of a roller
coaster there's been so many ups and
downs that started with them with a
20-point lead and it was a totally
unnecessary election she had purely to
get more power you know all those Daily
Mail headlines curse the saboteurs I
mean I was meant to be a goner myself I
had a very small I think I was the most
vulnerable in London second most
vulnerable in the whole country I came
back from a majority that was 200 odd to
nearly fourteen thousand so I mean it
was a massive miscalculation and you
know to call in the election for a
stronger hand for brexit and then to
lose your majority just unbelievable I
mean we have 37 new colleagues now 37
net games that some games that we made
so I mean but then she has got this
longevity as you say because everyone
thought she would be a goner by
Christmas and she's clinging on know in
terms of the winners and losers from the
general election but I never like to
call anyone within punching distance you
know a loser because you know it can
come back the other way but you know
arguably Joanna
I mean each one of you here in a
different way lost the election didn't
you well we you can't see the SNP lost
the election in Scotland cuz we've got
35 extra man
I guess Robertson well we've got 35
votes the 59 seats in Scotland more than
all the other parties put together and
now we're really in the position that
everyone expected us to be in in 2015
when we had that really quite amazing
landslide - more than 50% of the votes
just it just a gentle the silencing of
things that course of course it's been
difficult for us to lose people of the
caliber of Alec and also our our
Westminster leader but really the real
issue here is that for trees I mean this
was a gamble that hasn't paid off and
now she finds herself at the Ransom of
eleven DUP MPs 11 MPs from the most
right-wing and marginal party in the
United Kingdom and we've already seen
that that's cost are over a billion
pounds and it's also cost her just lost
huge face in Brussels because she was in
the verge a couple of Fridays ago of
reaching a deal one phone call to Arlene
Foster and the rug was pulled under from
under Theresa Mae's feet so I think the
real issue here is that the SNP are
still the largest party in Scotland by a
country mile and interestingly maybe
viewers in England don't realize this
the Tories have now in Scotland dropped
back to third place in the pool the
pools labour are back at second place
and with Davis taking fright so much for
her chances of being first minister in
Scotland that she's looking to bail and
get a Westminster seat
to be fair I mean if the DUP did quick
the rug out from under the feet of
treasom a you know in a few day a few
days after they can I pretty quickly
shoved it back under I mean we have no
moved on to phase 2 that is an
achievement isn't it yes I think it's a
significant achievement actually Roopa
was talking about the Prime Minister
clinging on you're talking about a weak
government really that's not proved to
be the case the Prime Minister has
accepted that she made a mistake over
called
calling the general election but since
then she's set about actually sorting
things out and I think this autumn she's
passed three huge tests first of all
she's demonstrated she can deliver a
budget many people said she couldn't
unsure delivered a successful budget
secondly despite the the one defeat last
week actually withdraw bill is
progressing well we're on track for
brexit and thirdly despite all the
casandra's all these predictions that it
would be a disaster we'd not open up
phase 2 she's shown determination
resilience
she's succeeded with phase 1 we're on to
phase 2 and BRICS this proceeding as
expected the other prediction though
that was made
about me 2017 was that the Labour Party
were to be entirely wiped out in the jet
in the general election you have to
admit Jeremy Corbyn has exceeded
expectations hasn't he
well there were very low expectations
for Jeremy Corbyn in the first place
okay Jeremy Corbyn won seats but it is
worth reminding people that still the
Conservative Party won the election
terms having the largest number of seats
and and being able to form a government
I actually think one of the things that
happened during that election one of my
reflections is we really didn't take the
economic argument strongly enough to
Jeremy Corbyn and we allowed Jeremy
Corbyn the Labour Party to get away with
this idea that you could spend huge
amounts of money whether it's on
scrapping tuition fees and scrapping all
the debt clearly not deliverable whether
it's nationalizing industries group and
I think that's something we need to take
on we did have a costed manifesto as did
the Lib Dems but the conservative one
there weren't any figures in it at all
and to see a leader of the Opposition at
Glastonbury having people chant his name
that's pretty unprecedented so I think
yeah they must have a also said to
Michael Eavis who'd be in Downing Street
by Christmas so you know so you'd have
peaks and troughs for Jeremy is
completely on the ropes Jeremy Corbyn is
still not ahead in the opinion polls and
they would disagree with Oliver the
reason Mays delivered a successful
budget one of the curiosities about
Briggs is it's such a disaster that it's
keeping us from focusing on the economic
disaster underlying breaks it we're by
this government haven't met any of their
targets a growth is at a record low it
reaches at least these are not my views
these are the views of the Office of
Budget Responsibility on the record
employment record low unemployment as an
economic disaster I'm talking about low
growth low productivity and squeezed
wages at the same time I mean the the
goalposts have slightly shifted and the
opposition benches you didn't think that
we were going to get to phase two I
don't think anyone necessary thought we
wouldn't get to fees too but the real
question is as some of your panelists
were discussing earlier it's what's
going to happen at the end of phase two
this wholly unrealistic attitude that a
trade deal can be delivered within the
space of a few months when we saw that
the seated real deal took years to
deliver and also this complete lack of
focus on the very important issue of
services which are so important for the
United Kingdom economy I mean they're
living a really living in cloud
cuckoo-land
I just wanted to broaden things a little
bit one of the interesting aspects one
of the most interesting aspects of this
year's the way in which they can have
the domestic political agenda is has
really been turned on its head I mean
the age of austerity it would appear to
and it was certainly that is not the
clamor for us to get down the deficit
get rid of the debt in the way that we
did before you look at incidents such as
you know Granville Tower and the broader
arguments about social and affordable
housing is that where the Labour Party
thinks it can make most games in 2017 on
the de met big domestic policy points I
mean again I think that
brexit played a part in that last
general election we want seats we've
never had before Kensington never before
Canterbury and so I think it's a sort of
mixture some issues around that no but I
think it was a combination of different
factors but grenfell is an appalling
sign of what happens when you don't take
poor people seriously I mean that was a
completely avoidable
adequate social housing yeah you can go
in a different direction in this you
know Scottish government has built over
30,000 affordable homes they're pledged
to build another 50,000 affordable homes
we've built many council houses unlike
the last Labour government has gotten to
only built six council houses and we've
now just last week introduced security
of tenure 50 prime finally and finally
you used those income tax parents that
you were given quite some time ago 7 out
of 10 Scots will now be better off as a
result of our income tax reforms in
Scotland along well I mean these these
parts took a while to burden the
Scottish government has been very busy
fighting a series of elections which
they didn't want and also an EU
referendum which Scots didn't want so
we've had our hands in number we have
also been introducing a new social
security in system in Scotland which is
a massive job with the 15% of social
security powers that have been devolved
to us but what matters now is that Derek
McKay has introduced a budget which
shows a difference of different
direction for the rest of the UK seven
out of ten Scots will be peeing less
income tax people are only less than 30%
people earning less than 30,000 a year
in the public sector are going to get a
three percent rise those earning above
30,000 you're going to get a two percent
rise these are steps that could be taken
by the Conservatives if they really
wanted to if they weren't so focused on
running down important areas result in
furtive I'm not in favor of putting up
taxes people earning over 33,000 pounds
a year that would be my constituency
there are lots of teachers in my
constituency lots of doctors who would
not appreciate having to pay with their
own Limon 33,000 pounds of more tax and
it's a difference between what I want I
want I don't I'd want I won't want to
end this on on a positive no I want
Christmas cheer to be the theme of the
day so I want my triumvirate of mystic
mugs to now start providing me with some
yes/no answers to some very straight
questions okay first question
to all three of you will there be an
election next year I think they'll cling
on as that's a no no definitely not
we're going to stick to this yes/no
thing guys will your party leader still
be in post this yes yeah yes 100% yes
that's a yellow card for you mister very
to shoot Donald Trump visit the UK in
2018 no no no way yes - good race
relations excellent will there be a
second referendum not anytime soon on
the EU joini not in 2018 definitely not
and a final question to you all at will
we be more prosperous outside the
European Union no way we can see it
already absolutely not we have a great
opportunity to seize it and we can do
much better outside right well I look
forward to receiving your Christmas card
straps I'm sure they've just been
delayed in the post at but for now
thanks very much for coming in and all
the best to you and your son Festa see
thank you to you